Now let's look at the relationship
between SMT, data cache, and TLB.
If we have a virtual index
virtually tagged cache,
then we simply send the virtual
address into the cache and
use the data that comes
out of the cache.
So with virtual index virtually tagged
cache is the problem is that our two
transmitters might have
different other spaces.
And now we are sending them
simultaneously to the cache.
The cache has no clue which
one of the two it's getting.
So, unless we make something really
complicated here to figure out
which is which, we will have some
alias in between the two threads.
Note that, normally with the VIVT cache,
when we switch
between threads in a coarse grain we
would flush the cache between that, but
now that the two threads can pretty
much every cycle you're getting one or
the other, we cannot flush
the cache in between those.
So with the virtual index virtually
tagged cache, we are running a real risk
of getting the wrong data because
the same address in the two threads that
are accessing the cache, pretty much
alternatingly in a very haphazard way,
might map to different
physical addresses.
But the data cache doesn't know that,
so one thread saves data to its stack,
another one pops data from its stack.
And if they're at the same virtual
address, we get the data forwarded from
one thread to the other
which we didn't want.
If we use a virtual index physically
tagged cache that avoids aliasing,
then we are fine.
We'll find the set in the cache and
the physical tags that come out will
be compared with those from the TLB.
So assuming that the TLB does
what it is supposed to do,
we will have the same virtual
address from the two threads.
Look at the same set, but
find different data based on
the physical address in that thread.
However, that assumes that when we use
a virtual address to access the TLB,
it doesn't look at just the page
number in the virtual address.
Because the two threads could
have the same page number
translate to different things.
So for virtual index physically tagged,
or physical index physically tagged
caches, the cache is just fine,
but the TLB must be thread-aware.
That can be done by adding
the single bit to each entry
that tells us which of the two
threads is this mapping for.
In that way, indexing into the TLB
with a virtual address will find a set
in the TLB, that has multiple entries.
And we will only be looking at
the entries that both match our virtual
page number, and
also match our thread ID.
So we will now send the page number and
also the thread ID here.
And the TLB needs to match both before
it treats this as a TLB hit and
produces the physical address here.